how many times have you ever spoken to
your son about his overseas business
dealings I've never spoken to myself
there's nothing there you should be
looking at Trump Trump's doing this
because he knows I'll beat him like a
drum never spoke to my son about
business now of course that's a lie if
you speak to your child about anything
occasionally work might come up how's
work going everything all right so what
do you do for a living son barisma
that's it Ukraine a lot of money you're
not qualified are you smoking crack you
must some of that might have come up
media coordinated to kill the stories
with the New York Post story right now
on Hunter Biden who even thought to make
that story up and he's in the midst of a
scandal he's not and he's taking two
years later you're confident based on
your analysis this is Hunter Biden's
data and that it's real yes once they've
figured out how to win the elections the
way they want them to be won then
suddenly the truth starts leaking out